Department of Justice opened a federal
civil rights investigation into this
weekend violence in Charlottesville
attorney general jeff sessions joins us
from the Department of Justice good
morning Attorney General morning yeah
why when many Republicans have
criticized him was the president's first
instinct not to speak out against white
supremacists and neo-nazis look he gave
a statement at a press conference a
parent that was already scheduled over
veterans issues it was a long statement
about our violence bigotry and hatred he
condemned it he called for unity in our
country
he called on us to get along with one
another and have love and affection and
and unity under the under the American
mr. Attorney General Constitution that's
what he he was strong about that it was
just shortly after the event happened
within a couple of hours actually from
him I'm sure knowing about it so I
thought that was strong and yesterday
his own spokesman explicitly condemned
by name the Nazis and that's the
spokesman that's a spokesman president
and but it's the president spokesman and
I'm sure he'll speak about it again but
his own spokesman said that I just think
we're making them too much out of this
fair enough that's why we're talking to
you but it's wrong to make a moral
equivalency between these two groups of
protesters is it not absolutely these
people are heather hire was out
protesting racism and bigotry she has a
right to do that that this individual
had no right to drive a car into them
and kill people and killing her and
injuring others series and some of them
very seriously this is absolutely
unacceptable
it cannot be countenance the president
has directed us to get after it our FBI
people are working on it assiduously
United States Attorney's and civil
rights divisions are focused on it
justice will be done
we're coming after these people it will
not be tolerated it cannot be tolerated
in America so to be clear does the
president today
need to specifically condemn neo-nazis
and white supremacists will he
absolutely he said it his spokesman said
it yesterday and I'm sure he'll read
reiterate that on in the days to come
actually we don't because there wasn't a
name attached to the White House
statement so there wasn't even a name
attached from the White House it was a
statement from the White House it
reflected his views and I think you
continue to hear it explicitly stated
but his condemnation of the ideology but
trying behind this evil white supremacy
hatred and bigotry ideology was consumed
roundly in his first statement this is
believed to be the largest white
supremacist demonstration in over a
decade we went and looked at the data
and in fact between 2001 and 2016 there
were nearly three times as many fatal
attacks by right-wing extremists than
Islamic extremists in the u.s. what is
the Justice Department need to be doing
Justice Department is focused on that
I'm briefed three times a week by the
FBI on terrorism and terrorism related
issues that includes briefings on
domestic terrorism and we will continue
to focus on that it will be a high
priority of the Department of Justice
let's determine if there are any
statutes of robert e lee and alabama
should they be taken down well this will
be decided by the state of Alabama the
cities and counties would you recommend
it has been my recommendation as
Attorney General of the United States is
that the cities and counties and states
have a right to decide their monuments
and that nobody should use violence to
stop them either way and you would not
happen making there should take them
down it's up to them to decide mr.
Attorney General Lindsey Graham said
that white supremacist groups and hate
groups believe they have a friend in the
White House do you do you believe that's
the case and if so how does that get
fixed I don't believe that's the case
and
the directions I've gotten from the
White House is what I believe and it's
what I believe is that we will not
tolerate this kind of hatred and
violence we will not allow these
extremist groups to obtain credibility
morally legally they are under
unjustified in their actions and
approach to American democracy
it cannot be countenanced mr. attorney
general let me ask you about your
relationship with President Trump about
two weeks ago he tweeted he called you
beleaguered and very weak how would you
characterize your relationship today
well I think it's a considerably better
I look forward to meeting with him today
he's asked to meet with me and FBI
director to discuss Charlottesville and
I appreciate that opportunity and I
share his vision for a lawful America
where people can walk the streets safely
without fear that children can play
outside and this surge in murders will
be reduced do you share his vision of
what he said about the leader of the
Senate Mitch McConnell well Mitch
McConnell is got a tough job it's a hard
job I know the president is frustrated
about the failure of the health care
bill and he speaks plainly when he
chooses to and that's his view at this
time and he's a right to express it mr.
Attorney General how long do you think
you'll be in this job well I intend to
serve as long as I can make a
contribution and as long as the
president wants me to serve he can he
can have as his attorney general someone
else if he chooses well he can ask me to
depart but I intend to fulfill my duties
I feel good about what we are
accomplishing I feel like we are
accomplishing the President's agenda in
an effective and professional way
utilizing the best of legal staff that
we have here will you one last question
will you make the issues that happened
in Charles bill a priority for you and
the Department of Jeff
it absolutely is there's no bigger case
right now that we are working on every
resource that's needed will be dedicated
to it we're going to study what happened
in in Charlottesville see if we can do
better in the future and I'll be asking
that we do that kind of thing today as a
matter of fact we'll have our top people
in Charlottesville on - thank you so
much mr. Attorney General thank you so
much for your time you